Hollywood loves sequels even if the
audience doesn't always agree here's a
handful of would-be franchise expanders
that didn't come anywhere near
duplicating the success of their
predecessors a Christmas story - my
summer story being a Hollywood producer
has its risks but at least you won't
shoot your eye out if you make a sadly
subpar and utterly unnecessary sequel to
a beloved holiday classic oh my god I
shot my eye out you'll shoot your eye
out
our proof lies in my summer story the
long delayed follow-up to a Christmas
story originally titled it runs in the
family this 1994 release did have a
couple ties to the original like being
based on stories by Jean Shepard who
returned to provide narration but given
that the entire cast of the original was
too old to reprise their roles a whole
new set of stars had to be moved in
including Charles Grodin and Mary
Steenburgen reviews weren't entirely
unkind with the film's box office gross
which total less than 71 thousand
dollars speaks for itself Legally Blonde
after 2003's Legally Blonde - red white
and blonde Reese Witherspoon was just
about done with the character of bimbo
turned lobbyist Elle Woods but after
watching the franchise continued without
her with a successful Legally Blonde
stage musical she took the reins once
more as producer of this 2009
direct-to-dvd spin-off the most
interesting and sad thing about the
movie is the involvement of director
savage steve holland who's once proud
filmography kicked off with a John
Cusack classic better off dead here
viewers watch as else twin cousins move
into her old house and you know what it
really isn't worth talking about the
plot suffice to say that small dogs and
a life lesson in the final actor
involved Ace Ventura jr. more than a
decade after Jim Carrey acted at the Ace
Ventura franchise someone got the bright
idea to continue the series without him
by attempting to tell the story of his
look like kid who gets mixed up in
solving some pet related wrongdoings
after a senior flies the coop it's a
horrible idea for
well even one that went direct video and
it was greeted with all the commercial
and difference in critical scoring you
might expect if it arrived in the 90s
you probably would have seen it at your
favorite blockbuster alas by the late
Ott's that could only gather dust on a
loneliest DVD rack at your local Best
Buy wargames the dead code unlike a lot
of technologically driven films wargames
remains a pretty solid little action
thriller not least because it boasts the
combined talents of Matthew Broderick
Ally Sheedy Dabney Coleman and Barry
Corbin none of the above returned for
the holy lamentable war games the dead
code which tried to duplicate the teen
hacker excitement of the original by
essentially copying the plot right down
to the reintroduction of wargames senior
computer whiz Stephen Falken played here
by a new actor who didn't even appear in
the original needless to say these new
wargames had no winners Adams family
reunion seeking to reboot the Addams
Family franchise after 1991 s The Addams
Family and 1993 s The Addams Family
Values Fox decided to start it over
again as a new TV show called the new
Addams Family featuring a new cache then
who had appeared in the movies and then
the studio filmed the made-for-tv movie
Addams family reunion which was supposed
to serve as the serious pilot even
though it had yet another cast of actors
in the lead roles confused yet just be
glad you weren't Tim curry or Daryl
Hannah both of whom somehow ended up
roped into this alternately unfunny and
offensive alleged comedy unsurprisingly
neither the movie nor the show it
launched had much of a legacy the new
Addams Family exit the airwaves after a
two season run and there have been no
family reunions since Roadhouse - last
call there are definitely people in the
world that would argue that Patrick
Swayze's Roadhouse is a classic it's
hard to imagine though that many of them
would go so far as to say we needed a
sequel let alone one starring Jonathan's
check if you remember him at all it's
probably from that thing you do you know
the whiny guitar player who didn't live
Tyler well now you can have Roadhouse -
to your list or don't probably don't
check stars a Swayze's characters son a
DEA agent who ends up running his
uncle's club after a local drug kingpin
beats him half to death
if you're guessing that the kid
ultimately discovers that the kingpin is
the same bad guy who murdered his dad
the nearest step ahead of the target
audience for Roadhouse
last call maybe go a step further and
skip this one and just watch that thing
you do again
man tooth fairy - you're setting a
pretty low bar for comedy when you hired
Dwayne the rock Johnson to run around in
fairy wings but even when it's held up
against the relaxed standard set by the
original Tooth Fairy its little seen
sequel is an ordeal the rock obviously
wasn't coming back for another round so
the producers hired Larry the Cable Guy
on the assumption that like the rock he
provoked laughs simply by strapping on
fairy wings it didn't work and neither
did hiring a pig as one of Larry's
co-stars splash - splash - was Disney's
attempt to cobble together a sequel to
its hit mermaid rom-com starring Tom
Hanks and Daryl Hannah
with neither star affordable enough for
a TV movie the studio almost completely
overhauled the cast originally broadcast
as a two-part event splash - has been
all but forgotten even the reissue
fanatics at Disney haven't gotten around
to putting it out on DVD or blu-ray
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation -
cousin Eddie's Island Adventure that's a
mouthful cousin Eddie the brain hick who
drove Clark crazy and a pair of national
lampoon's vacation movies could be
fairly funny in limited doses naturally
this was all the justification the
studio needed for basing an entire
vacation movie around Eddie after Chevy
Chase in beverly d'angelo were finished
with the franchise the horribly titled
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation -
cousin Eddie's Isle adventure starts
with Eddie losing his job to a monkey
and goes downhill from there with star
Randy Quaid huffing and puffing his way
through a series of increasingly lame
pratfalls maybe the movie would have
turned out better if they just replaced
Quaid with a monkey all together
just kidding we still love you Randy and
last and equally least bachelor party to
the Last Temptation Studios cranked out
a ton of sex comedies in the 80s and
1984 his bachelor party
would have been just another one of them
if it's star Tom Hanks hadn't gone on to
superstardom later in the decade more
than 20 years later Fox tried making
lightning strike twice with bachelor
party - The Last Temptation it was a
sequel in name only they gathered up a
group of stock character types - love
for the cameras in between gratuitous
topless shots
sadly for the studio the next Hanks
doesn't seem to have been in the cast
but that doesn't mean we won't hear
about a bachelor party three in 20
- thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which obscure
movie sequels should have made the list